the breaking news this morning five
missiles have hit the western ukrainian
city of levive now earlier i spoke to
the former head of the british army who
told us that he thinks the strikes are
evidence of russia softening up ukraine
ahead of a major land offensive to hit
the east he fears that the conflict
could last for months or even years with
ukraine having to give up parts of its
territory stay tuned for more of the
interview now meanwhile the country's
president has warned that russia wants
to destroy the donbass president
zelensky said that the aim was to wipe
other cities in the region off the face
of the earth let's get the latest
developments in the war well the mayor
of love says there have been five
targeted strikes on the city an area
where millions have fled the russian
invasion at least six people are
reported to have been killed in those
attacks
now ukraine warns that russia's
continued strikes in mario poll could be
a red line that ends all efforts to
reach peace through negotiation
and president zielenski said the russian
troops in the south of ukraine have been
carrying out torture and kidnappings of
local government representatives and
anybody deemed visible to local
communities
now earlier we spoke to the former head
of the british army lord dana who told
us that he believes it's only a matter
of time before mario paul falls he also
said he fears that the company could
drag out for months or even years with
ukraine being forced to cede some of its
territory
securing a land corridor from crimea
which viewers will remember was seized
by russia
in 2014
but crimea hitherto has been only
accessible to the russians by sea
now that they have almost completed
seizing a land corridor
from crimea through mario paul to the
donbass region which of course links
with russia proper they will then have
joined up the dots if you like between
crimea and russia proper but in a sense
this is something of a sideshow now
although an important one an important
strategic objective of the russians what
we're really what we should be focusing
on
is the russian likely significant attack
from the east pushing west to secure the
two provinces of luhansk and diets and
the and the shelling that's been widely
reported over the last few days right
across
ukraine i think one has to see that as
being part of a preliminary operation by
the russians prior to launching their
ground defensive uh in the east this
morning we've heard of at least five
missile strikes on lev that's of course
in the west of ukraine it's a place
where many people have fled to on their
way out of the country what does that
tell us do you think about perhaps the
change in tempo of the russian invasion
well i think what that does tell us
is that the
russian attack in the east that i was
talking about just a moment ago
uh is being properly prepared for this
time
what we saw right at the start of this
conflict that uh strike haphazard strike
south from belarus towards kiev was a
very uncoordinated operation which as we
all know uh ultimately failed
other vladimir putin has put general
alexander vornikov
in charge of operations uh in ukraine
and he is preparing this major strike in
the east striking from the east towards
the west and as part of the preliminary
operations for that ground maneuver
we're seeing artillery strikes across
the length and breadth of
of uh ukraine even as far to the western
city of lev
now
this is for two two reasons one is
probably to continue to try and
undermine the will of the ukrainian
people i think that'll be largely
unsuccessful as their spirit is is quite
fantastic but secondly i think the
russians are
targeting
um military hardware
depots factories and trying to erode and
reduce the capability of the ukrainian
armed forces to resist their strike when
it comes in the east so i think we see
the cruise missile strikes the artillery
strikes right across ukraine as being
part of the
the softening up if you like the
preliminary operations before the major
land strike which will occur
sometime in the next few days or weeks
ukrainians desperately uh
want to continue the fight and be
successful and vladimir putin has got to
have some kind of success that he can
report to his people so i think what
we're going to see going back to what i
said a few moments ago
is having achieved that land corridor
from crimea to the donbass we're then
going to see this
meticulously prepared i think this time
attack by the russians into the donbass
region to secure those two provinces and
then threaten to move further west
and i'm afraid that the russians having
captured those areas in the east having
captured that land corridor will not
want to give that up and it may well be
that over the time ukraine may have to
accept that it's lost part of its
territory russia will not easily give up
that territory and frankly why should it
who can make them do so and nato is not
going to make demand a major operation
and throw them out and if the ukrainians
can't and it may well be an ask too far
for the ukrainians to throw the russians
out then this may well become a
stalemate
um over a period of months and years
whereby the russians have controlled the
east have controlled that land corridor
and the ukrainians are left with about
85 of their territory